queremos encontrar la derivada con
respecto a x de ea la x que multiplica
coseno de x entonces bueno como siempre
te invito a que lo intentes a que pongas
pausa el vídeo intente resolver esto
para resolver esto veamos que sabemos
sabemos que la derivada con respecto a x
de ea la x
a la equis y sabemos que la derivada con
respecto a x de coseno de x es menos
seno de x pero como lo hacemos para
encontrar la derivada del producto de a
la xy coseno de x para encontrar esta
derivada lo que necesitamos es la regla
del producto que es esta si queremos
tomar la derivada con respecto a x de la
primera expresión en términos de x que
vamos a llamar de x multiplicada por
otra expresión también en términos de x
que llamaremos vdx esto será igual a la
derivada de la primera expresión
entonces tenemos un prima de x
multiplicada por la segunda expresión
así sin tomar su derivada entonces
tenemos un prima de x por feve x más la
primera expresión sin tomar su derivada
de x multiplicada por la derivada de la
segunda expresión de prima de x
ahora para facilitar recordar la regla
del producto tú tienes aquí dos
expresiones y para derivar la
multiplicación de dos expresiones lo que
haces es tomar la primera expresión
derivarla multiplicarlo por la segunda
expresión así sin tomar la derivada más
la primera expresión sin tomar la
derivada multiplicada por la derivada de
la segunda expresión y es una regla del
producto la derivada con respecto a x
dvd x por fede x es igual a prima de x
por b de x + de x por b prima de x ahora
sí vamos a resolver esto que en realidad
nos sirve como ejemplo para entender
mejor la regla del producto que aquí se
ve bastante abstracta entonces ud x será
a la x lo puse en color verde bebé x
será coseno de x lo puse en color rosa y
esto de los colores es solamente para
facilitar el entendimiento de la regla
del producto muy bien entonces si ud x
es igual a la x sabemos que la derivada
de a la x es a la x
a veces las matemáticas pueden ser
bastante curiosas entonces un prima de x
es igual
ayala x porque la derivada de a la x es
la equis y b prima de x es igual a menos
seno de x entonces ya con esta
información a que será igual esto será
igual a la derivada de la primera
expresión es decir la derivada de a la x
que es simplemente a la x multiplicada
por la segunda expresión sin tomar la
derivada así que tenemos a la x
multiplicada por coseno de x más
la primera expresión sin tomar la
derivada
a la x multiplicada por la derivada de
la segunda expresión entonces tenemos
que a la x x menos seno de x ahora aquí
no te confundas a la x en su misma
derivada pero aquí está es la derivada
de a la x que sea la x aunque acá no es
así aquí es a la x sin tomar la derivada
de la x muy bien ahora ya que está
aclarado eso vamos a simplificar esto
será igual
ayala x x coseno de x
- x
x ahora aquí podemos factorizar ayala x
entonces esto será igual
ayala x
que multiplica
a coseno de x menos
seno de xy bueno listo ahí está espero
que este ejemplo te haya servido para
entender mejor la regla del producto